détendez-vous relaxez-vous vos commentez
à dormir avec le 1 le 2 et le 3 dormi
bonsoir alors rendez-vous présente plus
vous êtes le Québécois qui hypnotise les
foules et les stars
[Rires]
intemporel actuellement au Grand Rex est
un carton il faut dire qu'en moins de 4
minutes les gens vous obéissent au doigt
et à l'oeil et croisons
[Musique]
alors Messmer vous êtes né le 2 août
1971 Québec père émerveillé journalier
dans une usine textile et c'est grâce à
votre grand-père que vous découvrez
l'art de l'hypnose
il était jockey son grand-père
essayait d'hypnotiser les cheveux de
course pour améliorer les performances
histoire du passé ça a fonctionnait mais
je l'ai vu moi hypnotiser des poulets à
l'époque alors
les poules c'est beaucoup plus facile
sur commande
la balance un peu et elle s'endort de
cette façon les coques ne pondent pas
d’œuf parce que c'est des coques non ils
vont pas se casser le cul pour 50
centimes d'euros
[Applaudissements]
alors
7 ans quand votre grand-père vous offre
un vieux livre où sont compilés tous les
secrets de l'hypnothérapie du 19e siècle
exactement j'ai eu ce livre là pour moi
c'est devenu un grimoire à mon livre de
chevet et à tous les soirs j'en disais
quelque part en cachette oui parce que
ma mère voulait pas que je lis ce livre
là elle pensait que j'étais pour faire
en sorte que je sois peut-être avec des
problèmes mental par la suite mais avec
ce livre vous tentez votre premier
expérience sur votre chien alors vous
dites c'est pas très compliqué
finalement il suffisait de trouver les
points de pression sur le coup
ouais c'est des zones hypnogènes on
appelle ça une zone hypnogène alors il
fallait trouver le bon endroit chez mon
chien et je l'ai trouvé assez facilement
et ça et j'allais endormi comme ça et du
coup j'ai eu quand même assez peur parce
que je pensais que je l'avais tué je
pensais il bougeait plus alors j'ai
essayé j'ai donné des petits coups comme
ça pour le réveiller mais non il restait
inerte ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'au moment où vous vous êtes au Québec
en train d'hypnotiser votre chien à
Paris Laurent Baffie découvre l'hypnose
sur un plateau dans l'émission 1 sur 5
oh c'est vieux ça présenté par Patrice
Laffont en regardant à quoi ça
standard tellement que
5 5 et 1 se détache automatiquement
l'une de l'autre sans la moindre
contracture douloureuse
repose lourdement de chaque côté de ton
corps
et aussitôt du tendon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
i j'avais mal au crâne je suis surveillé
que j'ai mal au cul je déteste l'hypnose
alors vous avez 9 ans quand vous essayez
vos talents pour la première fois sur un
être humain c'est un son s'appelle
Guilain dans le camarade de classe vous
lui suggérez de garder le bras tendu et
il rentre au Front national
mais en fait après il arrive plus à
plier son bras et quand vous essayez de
lui faire payer sur moi ça lui fait mal
et vous entendez un craquement
et je la vois pleurer et je pensais
qu'au départ il faisait semblant et
quand j'ai vu pleurer là j'ai dit non
écoute non mon ami de devant qui pleure
devant moi ça irait là c'est réel je le
vois la pénible dans ses yeux et
moi-même j'ai eu un coup de panique
parce que je me suis dit ben écoute ok
sombre mais comment je le ramène alors
j'ai repris le livre et j'ai trouvé la
recette
les expériences continuent mes
secrètement parce que c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque quand même l'hypnose avait
encore je m'en souviens moi il me reste
images c'était assimilé ou satanisme des
années 60 exactement j'ai gardé ça pour
moi un jardin secret je continue de
pratiquer seul dans ma chambre à faire
des suggestions à visualiser à augmenter
cette puissance et seulement un cercle
fermé d'amis de premier cercle je savais
ce que je faisais mais encore là j'en
parlais pas beaucoup et à 16 ans je vous
rêvez de devenir DJ et là
[Musique]
le destin un pote est OK pour vous
laisser mixer à sa place dans un
restaurant et quand vous arrivez le mec
coupe le son il prend le micro et il
annonce que vous allez faire une
performance d'hypnose c'est pas du tout
ce que vous attendiez vous êtes pris de
panique et puis vous jetez à l'eau et là
vous arrivez à en quelques clients pour
leur faire danser la lambada oui
exactement j'étais tellement timide à
l'époque je n'ai même pas osé dire non
alors je vais ouais bonsoir
artiste invité et là j'ai eu un coup de
panique incroyable mais au final
j'entends la voix de mon père qui dit
vas-y fonce et ça a commencé comme ça
c'est incroyable parce que vous
découvrez ce jour-là ce que vous voulez
faire dans la vie en fait exactement
ce soir là j'ai vu une vingtaine de
personnes dans un état hypnotique et ça
m'a bluffé moi-même
alors au début des années 90 vous ouvrez
un cabinet d'hypnothérapie à Montréal
vous traitez les addictions les phobies
le mal de dos persistant mais en fait à
l'époque l'hypnose est encore considéré
comme un boulot de charlatan absolument
absolument vous montez votre premier
numéro mais vous faites la tournée des
barres des cabanes enfin c'est pas
évident c'est pas évident parce que
imaginez tout le monde danse dans la
discothèque et à minuit on ferme la
musique et on me dit maintenant on a un
spectacle
en plus les gens sont bourrés ouais les
gens sont bourrés mais quand j'en dors
une personne là il y a un silence qui se
crée dans la salle oh merde il s'est
passé quelque chose en fait la tournée
des balles les cabarets peu à peu vous
faites remarquer et là vous devenez
Mesmer en hommage à France Anton Messmer
médecin autrichien du 18e siècle
fondateur de la théorie du magnétisme
animal premier hypnotiseur et en anglais
on dit mesmerize ce qui veut dire
hypnotiser en fait et en 2009 vous
explosez au Canada avec votre show
télévisé Messmer drôlement mystérieux on
évitait des stars on a invité aussi des
gens du public pour faire l'émission et
à ce moment-là mais quand hypnotise des
stars le scepticisme tombe aussi en 2013
vous endormez Augustin Trapenard dans Le
Grand Journal d'Antoine de Caunes non
mais c'était la première fois moi c'est
là que je vous ai vu pour la première
fois et ensuite avec Arthur vous
deviendrez l'hyp plusieurs des stars
de personnalité qui est plus sensible à
l'hypnose
c'est une question de connexion qu'on
doit créer entre la personne qui veut
vivre entre vous
et on a prouvé parce qu'on continue à
rechercher tout ça mais on peut
maintenant le voir à l'IRM qu'une
connexion qui s'établit entre geek ouais
un peu comme un Bluetooth un peu comme
un blé en wifi il y a des gens qui font
semblant d'être hypnotisés et vous
pouvez le savoir vous oui encore hier
dans mon spectacle deux personnes qui
étaient sur scène et je les voyais
écoute j'arrive tout près d'eux ils
rouvre les yeux ils disent les refaire
dès lors après Arthur votre spectacle
bah tous les records d'affluence et
effectivement alors comment vous faites
vous commencez par un test de
réceptivité c'est la sexualité souvent
dans le spectacle c'est les mains qui se
collent ensemble par exemple son premier
test après oui il y en a 40 qui montent
sur scène là ils ont sélectionné 15 à 18
ans et on essaie de faire le choix avec
eux ça commence donc vous les replonger
par exemple dans leur enfance il se
réveille pas mais ils vont toujours
s'éveiller c'est impossible
il y a des gens que vous replongez dans
Cro-Magnon un nombre de Cro-Magnon alors
chercher des poux dans la tête de leurs
voisins
alors sérieusement le truc le plus
dingue que vous ayez fait par exemple la
fille qui croyait qu'elle travaille avec
son mari la Pénélope
[Rires]
le plus dingue écoutez
j'aime les trucs à performance comme
dans le dernier émission qu'on a fait
avec Baptiste de biconi quand je l'ai
plongé dans une baignoire avec des
glaçons l'eau et des glacés à deux
degrés Celsius ou un degré Celsius alors
moi ça me bloque à chaque fois quand je
vois qu'il peut entrer dans une
baignoire d'eau glacée et qui a aucun
choc thermique et il rentre là-dedans
comme c'est un bassin d'eau chaude une
baignoire d'eau chaude et il peut même
prendre un petit pina colada et ça c'est
vraiment bluffant ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que après il y a
pas de traumatismes enfin comme si on se
réveille dans le cauchemar parce que
vous dites d'ailleurs le subconscient
nous protège nous protège
l'environnement qui est très frappant
c'est l'histoire du pistolet
tire toi une balle dans le cœur et ben
finalement vous dites ça serait avec un
vrai pistolet il le ferait pas parce que
dès qu'on transgresse nos limites
morales le subconscient on va regarder
d'ailleurs
jusqu'à présent Messmer nous a fait rire
à la fin du spectacle il va nous mettre
mal à l'aise
[Musique]
il endort sa deuxième sélection de
spectateurs avec ce qu'il appelle un
pistolet à sommeil sur scène l'une des
femmes sous hypnose semble choquer
Messmer va pourtant l'encourager à
utiliser elle-même le pistolet
Antoine Biol le thérapeute tique un peu
avec l'hypnose ce qui pourrait être
profondément déstabilisant pour
quelqu'un
de fait à la demande de Messmer la femme
finit par retourner le pistolet à
sommeil contre elle la scène peut
choquer Messmer le sait très bien
j'aime faire ce genre de numéro où on va
la limite du politiquement correct
à chaque fois que je le fais mais ça me
permet de l'expliquer ça ça me permet
par la suite de dire écoutez si j'avais
mis un vrai pistolet elle aurait bloqué
la suggestion elle aurait complètement
refusé tout ça alors le 4 janvier 2017
vous avez pu le réaliser le record du
monde en hypnotisant 854 personnes
Hollande a fait mieux
en 4 minutes en moins de 4 minutes et
jusqu'à aujourd'hui vous avez hypnotisé
125 000 personnes vous êtes au Grand Rex
jusqu'à quand on est là du 18 mai au 22
mai sinon tournez par toi à travers la
France en plus les gens oublient qu'ils
ont payé donc ils reviennent
il a bien dans le groupe
[Applaudissements]
alors un truc sur Thierry on peut la
laisser avec les rouges
on va crever on va travailler
alors tout le monde on décroise les
jambes on place les deux pieds au sol
bien sûr alors on essaie en place les
deux mains comme ça ici ok les deux
pompes de main jointes ensemble ok on
déplie les index on prend les index en
direction du plafond on ouvre les doigts
on fait un espace de 1 cm entre les deux
doigts fixer l'espace fixez les vies
entre les doigts imaginez maintenant que
je transperce les doigts avec une vis et
je prends la vis et je serre la vis
maintenant et regardez vos doigts qui se
rapprochent se colle et se rapproche de
plus en plus de mieux en mieux et doit
se rapproche et ce qu'on a encore de
plus en plus fort de plus en plus collés
de plus en plus soudés il doit rester en
coincé à mon signal au compte de 3
regardez vos doigts et avec le 1 les
doigts colle avec le 2 de plus en plus
collé comme des aimants vaudois demeure
avec le 3 impossible de les séparer même
si vous tentez de le faire les doigts ne
bougent plus collées et soudés ensemble
n'est-ce pas
les paupières se ferment
les yeux fermés ouvre votre esprit
concentrez-vous sur ma voix
détendez-vous relaxez vous commencez à
dormir avec le 1 le 2 et le 3 dormez
profondément vous vous sentez
merveilleusement bien dans un monde de
rêve et d'imaginaire et continuer de
dormir tout va bien concentrez-vous sur
ma voix vous continuez de dormir peu
importe ce qui se passe et tant je vous
dirais pas le contraire dans un monde de
rêve et d'imaginaire alors maintenant on
va le laisser dormir l'émission est
terminée c'est ça
et maintenant Thierry a mon signal
toujours dans un état d'hypnose aller
ouvrir les yeux regardez tous les
invités
ça va
elle est fatiguée je suis fatigué vous
me l'avez tous fatigué
[Applaudissements]
tout va bien profiter du moment et
dormez tout va très très
revenir à la conscience avec un bel
énergie
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu